speaking of chip uh
chipotle
is revolutionizing things you know you
were just talking about technology
that's gonna bring us forward and is
gonna bring people back to life well the
technological revolution is already in
front of us
in the fast casual sector
chipotle
is testing a robot that's going to make
tortilla chips i thought the tortilla
chips were already made in a factory i
don't know like who's making them made
fresh
chipotle is testing and
[ __ ] yuma
testing a new tortilla what did you do
rip it
why did you rip the tea up
[Applause]
piece of gob
piece of gob
testing a new autonomous kitchen
assistant to handle cooking up one of
its core menu items tortilla chips
the company's culinary [ __ ] yeah
technology teams [ __ ] yeah
are working with miso robotics oh miso
robotics you so robotics
we sell robotics
to customize its latest device
dubbed
me so horny robotics
chippy [ __ ] yeah
chippy the robot [ __ ] yeah
chipotle is inventing a robot named
chippy yup
hey metal pekka
[ __ ] yeah
to cook and season chipotle's chips with
salt and fresh lime juice fresh lime
juice give it a slap in the face
cause it's fresh it's fresh
through artificial intelligence uh oh
artificial insemination
pekka juice
chippy chippy
is trained to recreate the exact recipe
yup i do it right every time
pecker made of metal
the robot is being tested at the
chipotle
cultivate center
the company's innovation hub in irvine
how come it's not out of ation
california and will be used in a
restaurant in southern california later
this year
socal yup so cal
the company is wrong did i just repeat
your non-remark
tippy a robot making yuma
the company is relying on the stage gate
process it uses for new menu items i'm
not a robot my name is rob ott
test making yuma
and learn from workers and guests
before deciding whether it should move
ahead with a national rollout of chippy
[ __ ] yeah
yuma i will do commercials
i don't know if chippy's gonna be the
mascot chippy just makes the chips yes
but i'm the mascot of the chip maker
you are the chipman
what a fun robot how come that robot has
a giant pekka
customers are going to wonder yeah
they're going to love it
chippy relies on some of the same tech
in miso robotics meso robotics uso
robotics we also robotics
ah
oh miso robotics
flippy 2 chicken wing making robot i
hate flippy flippy is a piece of garbage
i hope flippy dies
[ __ ] flippy
[Laughter]
including
the same arm and a similar frame
ceo
oh no
ceo where is eo
i heard eo
the ceo of miso robotics
is mike bell
[Laughter]
i do not compute
hey
hey bae
it's mike bell making a duck belt how
great would this be [ __ ] robot just
making tortillas
i can dug it family reunions put some
miso robotics on my sushi
mike bao makes robots to make fast food
like belle mike
said the company's robots are also being
used at white castle for burgers
and we're tested
at inspire brands buffalo wild wings for
wings
you